Okay,
let's get started
in your current movie over
the break that Goldman Sachs
get some bad press.
Is there,
is that, has anybody read
the beach in rolling stone?
Okay.
We're good at the end mark.
Yeah. I'm Matt [inaudible]
Goldman Sachs a, um,
and I did this go wrong. It's something
along the lines of a grade. Bam.
Higher Squid were, that was the jammy.
It's anything that smells like money.
I think that's an exact quote.
Yeah,
we should try that out on power.
It also reminds me of a
passage in Richard Posner,
Xbox,
uh,
to the effect that we can no more blame
the financiers or the record of the
credit markets,
then we could blame a
lion freaking a zebra.
And
there's an odd,
this continuity here.
When you look at Goldman Sachs internally,
uh,
through the eyes of one of
its very senior partner,
uh,
the ethical component is big.
There's a huge component about,
uh,
integrity and meeting one's obligations
and delivering the highest quality
product on the market.
Uh,
and at the same time,
Goldman is vulnerable to the view that
if tour in order to advantage of the tax
payers in a recent debacle,
now how would they defend themselves?
They would say one thing they would say
is we didn't want to pick the money.
Hey Paulson and told us
we had to take the money.
But because the stigma which
would otherwise fall on the bank,
which you talked to,
the money
would cause further
disruption and meltdown.
That's one thing they would
say. Um, another thing,
well, if you noticed what they're doing,
the in the way of charitable activities,
just lightly, everybody notice, uh,
announcement $500 million.
It helped to 10,000 small businesses.
Uh, does that strike you as a
big gesture or a little desk
tell?
What do you call or anything?
Oh, has it, what percent
of their revenues,
profits or even just at an APM bonuses
every year? I would say that's very little
gesture. The very little gesture. I agree.
From a public relations point of view,
if they multiplied it by 10,
so it's 5 billion,
would it do the more good them?
Not the world,
not the country down
where zero's probably make, I've made
a difference in how the Canadian, um,
but I don't know if it
would believing up for
a cost consciousness.
Okay.
So my own intuition is that it
wouldn't do them a lot of good
that the public doesn't
think quantitative way.
Some opinion leaders do,
but most people,
500 million sounds like an awful lot of
money and 5 billion doesn't sound like
10 times as much. Uh,
so there are probably,
they're probably not far off in the
number they chose if the [inaudible] is
public probation's,
which I think it is. Uh,
how many are there people here who think
that the government ought to compel
them to give back a bigger chunk of
capital to put it out there in some
charitable way or give it
back to the tax payers?
Maybe anybody have that view
and, okay, so, so you're unanimous,
which is rare birth this size.
Uh,
does that mean that you think there's
no ought to it or does it mean,
so that the process by which
the government would do
that strikes you as not a
good one?
Who's got to rescue me here guys,
I'm drowning.
There's a big difference between
what we should do. They can make you,
I don't think that there's any of using
virtual patients should be forced,
you know, each charity unless
it's like a ad hoc tasks are,
and then we applied to them and
that seems like a little teenager.
Okay.
So if,
if probably would violate the constitution
if we created the Goldman Sachs
recognition act.
Um,
I agree with that.
So we're coming to the end of the course
and what I want to do is today to add
one more case,
one which allows us to look at
the interface between capital,
the environment and government in the Txu,
EDF,
a case which you've all looked at and
which is structured so that you could
invest a whole week if you
were willing to trace outs,
temporary strand in the, in the, uh,
a web page.
And then on Wednesday I'm going to do
a read a recap of the course as if on a
motorcycle,
uh,
and finish with a shell.
Cool case.
Quick will form the basis for your final
exam as shy and sensitive to account
for 70% of the final.
I'm sure we'll have a hundred percent
attendance during the last 20 minutes of
class. And, uh, I'll, I'll
get, I'll give you the,
give me the, the reading assignment
and advantage. It is the,
uh, leasing the rain. It's the, the,
the reading is the William Finnegan
piece from the New Yorker about the
privatization of the water
supply of Cochabamba Bolivia,
a by an American corporation
known as Bechtel. Uh,
and the essay question,
all the formula at the end of class
Wednesday asks you to work through that
story and as somebody who has learned
something about capitalism in this course.
Yeah.
Okay. So now marrying the devil. And
the
well,
difficulty with this
case is that it's full,
full backgrounds and I,
these are the most important or most
immediately important of the acronyms.
And,
um,
can anybody here quickly recite the
full lane of every one of these?
Who wants to be a show off?
I'm sure there are 50 people
who can do it in this room.
Okay.
I'll,
let's put them into three bins.
Um,
this is the most obscure
Texas climate initiative.
Uh,
and Jim Marsden,
who is a video star of the case,
is president of that.
Uh,
and he is the regional head of EDF,
the Environmental Defense Fund for Texas
a and the natural resources defense
council is a,
is parallel to the EDF,
a little harder edge,
uh, and important, oops. Can't, yeah.
Here we go.
Then in the gray box in the middle,
we have the target firms in
the private equity takeover.
Uh, it's just one for
a really, it's Txu. Uh,
but the focus strategically is on
Txu plus it is on the expanded,
uh, generation capacity
that Txu has announced.
And that expanded generation
capacity is on the lower edge.
From an environmental point of view.
It relies on conventional technology,
which no one thing,
no one thought at the time was the
best available technology for coal fire
generation of electric current.
Uh,
and while we're at it,
the parts of a,
an electric utility company are three
generation transmission and sales or
distribution.
Transmission is the long lines and
distribution is the last mile of lines and
the financial connection,
the contractual connection
with the customer.
I then on the right,
we've got KKR and TPG
and these are both large,
uh, and uh, very aggressive.
Uh,
private equity firms.
KKR is most famous or the,
uh,
the Reynolds' Nabisco, Rjr Nabisco, uh,
takeover,
which is characterized at length in our
variants of the gate and Texas Pacific.
Uh,
is actually the more interesting of the
two from the point of view of this case
or any,
anybody snap to a,
an obvious conclusion about
the difference between the two.
Okay.
We'll draw it out in a few minutes.
The TXU expansion,
uh,
8,600 megawatts added.
That's a just under 50% incremental to
the firm's total generating capacity.
Uh,
10 or $11 billion in cost.
somewhere between half
1,000,000,002 billion of that
are budgeted to controls of
pollution.
And it's pretty murky in the case and
pretty murky in fact just how much it
would cost. How much of the capital
can be construed as pollution control.
Uh,
they promised a 20% cut any missions.
What do they mean by that?
Who thought that one
through 20% cut of emotions,
we're going to add 47% of our total
generating capacity and we're going to cut
emissions by 20%.
What exactly is the claim?
Does it meet?
Yes.
I'm not sure what TXU problems exactly,
but there are two ways you can do that.
You can artificially Nicu my carbon
credits or reduce your emissions intensity
on paper.
You can also retrofit
some coal plants and see,
um, so that emissions are kind
of sequestered from the ground.
Like there are certain
technologies allow you to do that.
So that's some ways you can cut it.
Okay.
Um,
those are both valid points,
but I'm still a little unclear about how
much salt is going to come out the end
of the pipe.
Yes,
I use,
I guess a of potential difference is
whether the 20% caught to Sam's little
missions or are generated.
So it was pretty unique generated there
would still be a larger percentage of
mission slowed would be less per unit.
Yeah.
I think it has to be a norm to in that
way it has to be a unit rate of emission
so that these planets are on average
quite a lot better than the old plants.
Uh,
those still not state of the art.
And the claim is that we're
going to drive the anger,
good emission rate per mega watt,
uh,
down by 20%. Uh, they're using old sites.
They plan to use the old sites
where they've already got a plan.
Anybody figure out why they
would say a thing like that?
Well,
yes Tom,
if you're building a new site,
it requires a lot more
regulatory approval. Greenfield,
Greenfield site, and you've got
a whole round of permitting. Uh,
and there are a couple
of other advantages.
One is that the up nimby politics,
not in my backyard,
politics are over in those areas.
You've already been through it. And if
you can come back to people and say,
this is a less disruptive
plant than the old one,
uh, that's a pretty good start. A,
and even if people aren't
much taken by that,
if you've been,
if the management has been intelligent,
they will have built a network
of local relationships,
which they would have to build a
new on a Greenfield site. Finally,
there's an infrastructure reason that
the transmission lines required to
transport the current produced a will
already be in place and that's both an
economic and a political plus a.
And then at the end of this they throw
in a 10% discount to their customers and
that discount is a nonsequitor
in the environmental discussion.
Uh,
but it's not a non sequitur in the actual
case because Txu is in trouble on to
political fronts at once.
It is a monopoly,
a seller of current,
and it has,
it is,
it has wired the state of Texas
politically and there is a populous revolt
against that.
And the populist revolt takes the form
of criticizing the ultimate pricing,
uh, at the household level. Now,
if we look at the case from Austin,
Texas,
we've got all these small things upper
right that our federal government,
uh,
and we've got all these big things
locally that are state politics and
government.
I,
you've got Texas state government where,
how,
how CXU doing with Governor
Perry during all this.
Is Perry a populous to
wants to beat up on them?
Now they own parent,
I've may overstate alone,
but they pretty much own governor Perry.
Uh,
the Texas business for clean air is a
not altogether surprising alliance of
business groups, uh, which, uh,
are opposed to Txu on this,
on environmental grounds, sometimes
for self-serving business reasons.
And other times I think because it's
what senior management thinks is right.
Uh, you've got Texans for
public. Josh does, and they're,
they're not so much about the
environment as about the rate.
Uh, you've got a state senator
named Troy Frazier who is, uh,
making a name for himself statewide by
attacking Txu on mostly on the rate side,
but he's also willing to take
up the environmental side. Uh,
you've got the Texas climate initiative
and EDF, which are closely or twine.
And the personality of Jim Marsden.
Uh,
what do you think of Martha? You, if
you went all the way through the case,
you hurt him,
I don't know,
five or seven times in
video seem like enable guy
a thumbs up if you think that
bounce down if you're
going to pay it back.
Hmm. We've got 95 abstentions. Yeah.
MMM.
Usually label guy.
He's a very able guy.
Uh,
but he is, he is a, uh,
he has a very soft style of argument.
Right.
And he never seemed to
be a jump ahead of you.
And the argument is always in a very
laid back way asking your opinion,
uh, as if he hadn't really figured
out where you wanted to go.
And that may be partly for our benefit
because he was working for the school of
management in preparing for the case.
But it's also probably
part of his natural style
puct public utility
commission of Texas and Texas
Commission on environmental quality.
I almost missed that one myself.
These are the two principal regulatory
bodies and the case and the Association
of electric companies of Texas.
You can imagine who they are.
And what [inaudible] role
is, it's a classic, uh,
Interest Association.
And then you've got popular.
Cool.
We're out here today as part
of a national day of action.
Target and Merrill Lynch
for backing TX shoes,
dirty coal plants,
poor profits, Morocco,
Asma, global warming.
Oh,
in cities like New York, Boston, San
Francisco, Washington, DC, Los Angeles.
And of course Houston.
Yeah,
we want Tia cue to stop this wrong headed
plan to build 11 new coal fire power
plants in Texas. We want
the banks, Morgan Stanley,
Merrill Lynch and Citibank
to scuttle the deal.
Deliver this letter or I'm
in the barrels is a letter
to Merrill Lynch knows best dirty
coal,
but they don't seem to
say we'll take the house but
I have an appointment.
Thirdly,
rehabbing appointment, we
have an appointment. Cheryl,
you and our relationship with
Merrill Lynch is quite tight.
Yep.
Okay.
So
did you guys ever done
in protest of that type
and you just don't look
like street theater times?
Do you think that's a factor?
You're shaking your head.
Okay. And I think there are
two sides to the question.
Let's start in the negative here.
I mean,
I just feel as though it's not in.
So we get the companies to change their
positions generally. So I mean, yes,
it might serve a little public
disapproval for a couple of days with this
machine.
Okay.
So as a direct strategy for changing
the Bader of companies goes nowhere.
We agree.
Is there any other way in which it might
be of service to the cause these are
pursuing
here and then
did you can get coverage on it.
It tends to have a more dramatic effect
on politics and yet I was working on a
political campaign where
you sell something that was
smart enough pay shine in
the Washington Post.
Um,
and so I know this from personal
experience that that uh,
it does have the potential,
probably not to effect the direct
response to the people are falling out,
but that they're a Margaret Ish.
Okay.
So the clear the media are the,
are the target and then who would we
most likely influenced with this sort of
thing.
Anybody want to elaborate further?
Yes,
Sasha.
What companies really worry about,
his other clients are going to be
sensitive to the native grass and changed
companies.
Absolutely.
That's okay.
Txu customer voter base is a part of this
and both of those nouns are important
in it.
They are both voters and customers and
they may not have many places to go as
customers,
but as voters,
the perception within regulatory
and legislative groups in Boston,
would it be, uh, an
important consideration?
I personally don't think that this kind
of demonstration is hugely effective,
but it does kind of raise the temperature
of the issue and make it salient to
decision makers in
government. Now, in all the,
if we switched from Austin
to Washington, uh, the,
the actors get deaf get,
get to be different.
And the EPA and the Federal
Energy Regulatory Commission,
uh,
and the key people in Congress
slide Henry Waxman or,
uh, Senator Bingaman and boxer, uh,
become big players and the EDF and the,
uh,
and our, uh, RBF, um,
national resource defense
funds become a well staffed.
They would each have 50 or so staff
people in Washington and become a major
presence.
And the question in front
of a Kkr and Texas Pacific,
a hindrance on why do,
why do they,
why are they messing around with
all these environmental groups,
which sounded like from a
purely economic point of view,
to be a waste of time. And yes, from a,
from an entirely rational economic
point of view, it isn't a waste of time.
Why not?
Well, let's look. Let's go to Wall
Street. The private equity business.
In 2007,
there were 794 a large private
equity transactions during that year,
uh, adding up to about 800 billion. So
they average about a billion of peace,
uh,
explosive growth.
They're up about a 400 and 450,
500% from 2000 to 2007.
Uh, and it's a period when capital
is abundant and cheap. So the,
the, it is in every sense, boom.
Time for private equity.
The,
um,
you've got
three sets of players as
seen from Wall Street.
You've got the private equity
firms, the target firms, uh,
and the business services organizations,
mainly investment banks,
which catalyzed a
transactions of this kind.
And the takeover of Txu is a mega deal.
It is the biggest transaction of its kind,
so it gets a lot of attention
and offers to be very profitable.
The
institutional investors showing up or
left in the blue box are limited partners
in the funds created by organizations
like Kkr and Texas Pacific.
And from their point of view,
this is one of the highest yielding,
uh,
asset classes in their portfolio.
Uh,
and David Swensen for example of Yale.
one of the things he did with the Yale
portfolio which made it grow so much
faster after he came then and had grown
at anytime in the university's history
was to shift a great deal of capital
away from publicly traded securities into
private Equity Funds,
which uh, which differ,
they defer the biggest difference between,
um,
how well best companies do,
would it stocks and bonds on the one side
and private equity on the other is the
difference between the smart money
and average money in the stock market.
The difference between very smart
money and fairly dumb money is a few
percentage points.
The difference in private equity between
the smartest money and fairly dumb
bunny is enormous. And so if, uh,
if a, a, an institutional
investor by Gail Harvard, uh,
or the big pension funds can get
into private equity with smart money,
hire smart management,
uh,
invest with people like
Texas Pacific and Kkr,
the opportunity to, uh, beat
the market in a big way, uh,
is a very right one.
And
that's the heart of this deal.
Now,
from a sociological point of view,
uh,
the people who run these,
these companies are pretty
far away from the green world,
uh, which centers in major
metropolitan areas, uh,
and it's populated by Welton do activists,
uh,
and they're five o one c,
three corporation of which,
uh,
uh, the, the ones in
play today are examples.
Now,
the Pacific group is a little different
from KKR in its relationship to those
groups because it has one key player in
William Riley who had been the head of
the EPA before and who is agreeing?
And he gave,
he gives Texas specific
a relationship to a,
to this world of which KKR
pretty much doesn't have that.
Ain't David Bonderman, who is, uh,
one of the founders of Texas Pacific is
a Harvard educated and kind of part of
this world. If you begin tracking
personalities in these funds,
uh, Francis Vita King, uh,
she of a Yale fame,
uh,
is the head of a natural
resources defense.
Fine.
I don't know why would seasons instead of
F's on the end of this other slide. Uh,
she,
she's the head of that and a
terrifically potent a leader.
And the reason the privileged access to
do this case came to the Yale School of
Management has something to do
with that particular connection.
Uh,
and there is a cultural divide here.
It is, uh, uh, it is,
these are quite different views of the
world and if we compare a five zero one c
three corporations with regular public
or not publicly publicly traded or not
publicly traded corporations,
we get some sharp contrasts.
The business corporations
are pursuing profit. A,
the five o one c three
s are pursuing a cost.
The
attitude to risk is far more
aggressive among the businesses.
Uh,
the boards are accountable to mainly to
major investors on the business side,
uh,
and uh,
to donors on the final one C3 side,
except that in the really big old five
[inaudible] they're accountable to no one
because the donor is dead. The
Carnegie Corporation, for example,
where my wife is a chief
investment officer,
Andrew Carnegie hasn't paid any
attention to their lenders in some time
and it actually creates an
enormous amount of, of, uh,
uh, free play at top
management and board level.
Uh,
the management culture on the business
side is far more aggressive than on among
the nonprofits and top
management compensation in it,
particularly in private
equity is high and variable.
And Jim would,
Jim pointed out to me that Jim Alexander
pointed up to me this morning that when
I say high and variable,
the variability may or may not be
well tied to actual performance.
You can get a lot of compensation for
just sitting in the right chair during a
bull market. And many people have. Um,
and on the nonprofit side,
if the compensation is
relatively modest and uh,
more or less in variant with performance,
uh,
take Francis by Nikki,
there was a to do a in the same year
because somebody published their top
salaries are always public and her salary
of $252,000 was published and there
was a populous outcry.
Now by private equity standards
that sound a lot of money,
uh,
even by not people on the investment side
and organizations like this make three
or four or 10 times that.
But the general norm in nonprofits is how
many are there people here who planned
the become nonprofit tiers?
Maybe?
Okay. Well the one thing you
have to do is take a zero off.
Uh, when you think about compensation,
uh, more or less, it's, it's,
that's about the ratio
and it's considerable. Uh,
so these are two very different
classes of organizations. All right.
Here we have Fred crop of the
natural resources and Henry Kravitz.
And I'll bet not one of you is
in doubt about witches switch,
but the pictures are then
you get the point across. Um,
and
why on earth would people on this side
be so interested in participation from
people on this side, Sasha, again,
um, to do something with the business
that makes them more money ultimately then
it's a good deal.
You nailed it.
And not,
not one iota of direct concern for the
environment is required to back that up.
Right? So what's the biggest
problem about Tia Queue?
Why is it,
what if you're going to get to sit down
and calculate the risks from Kkr and a
specific point of view
of taking over this firm,
what would the main risk
speed they would be?
Would they be that the
technology will fail?
Would they be that consumer demand for
electric tower will suddenly go away?
Would they be that a new
entrant will come in,
a large new amber will come in and
begin to compete with lower prices?
None of those things or arc imaginable.
None of those are imaginable.
So why isn't this Josh a
license to print money?
And the answer to that is that a
regulatory risk is substantial at both the
federal and state levels, much more
substantial at the federal level.
And that the,
the process by which the,
the groups would in effect bless or kosher
the transaction is a way of limiting
political risk.
Oh,
the eat the EDF is all about
the cause of the environment.
Um,
and their claim is that a
lobby work they've done in
the years from 2001 to 2008
will, uh, diminish, uh,
diesel pollution by nearly 90% by 2030.
And that's their business.
Their business is to get the government
to compel companies to pollute less,
uh, Fred crop at Davos
in the year of the case.
This is not in the case. The smartest
companies can see over the horizon,
anticipate consumer demands.
That's why the EDF has been able
to team with a team up with Alcoa,
dupont, Caterpillar, GE,
Duke, the Duke Energy,
BP America and others on a plan that
could cut greenhouse gas emissions by 68%
by 2050.
The plan is a job,
Twitter as well as an
environmental winter. So the,
so organizations like these are brokers.
Yeah.
Which they cut deals with businesses and
the businesses they cut the deals with
our one switch have a higher than
average capacity to withstand pilar
regulation.
For example,
Ge with ECO imagination,
you've all heard of that.
If you watch television for any
period of as as long as an hour,
you have been saturated with that message.
And why can he do that?
Well why does it have to do it?
What street is long term reputation
for environmental pollution?
It is that they filled the Hudson
River with PCPs 50 years ago and it's
important for them to get us off that
topic and to think of them in an in a
different way.
Second,
if they compete in Europe
for the manufacturer of
electrically powered equipment
and the regs in Europe are much tighter
than they are here from an environmental
point of view.
So they have developed a technology
to meet Mike higher standards.
They've got it already in the kit.
And so from their point of view,
it is actually a corporate strategy play
to encourage the feds to raise the bar
cap and trade. I'm running out of
time here. Cap and trade diagram.
Uh, the interesting side fact
that cap and trade in the EU,
uh,
basically fizzle and it fizzled because
the caps that were put on the countries
were not low enough to make
people go out and buy credits.
They were sat in a very gentle political
way and the market for cap and trade
depends on people having to break the
caps and buy credits to make up for that.
And the caps were set so high that
it didn't produce the desired effect.
I don't know why that slide is there.
No.
Um, let's think about outcomes. Uh,
we've got on the vertical dimension
Greenwald and on the horizontal dimension,
Green Paper and uh,
four big quadrants. The four
quadrants of this space, uh,
define,
uh,
points we could think about in
looking at what the risks are,
the possibilities of this
are for these two classes of,
of organizations down here,
emissions are high end profits are low,
is a catastrophe.
On both dementia.
And the likelihood of both of those
things happening is very small.
A story where you have both
high emissions and high profit.
This is the most worrying category
from the point of view of the EDF.
This would,
this would constitute greenwashing,
which has become a really
important epithet in the
politics of the environment.
Where are their blessing something
which is a retention benefit to the
environment.
And here is the disaster from the point
of view of Kkr and Texas Pacific where
you have both low
emissions and low profits.
And
do you think KKR and Texas Pacific enter
into this relationship fearing the risk
that EDF and the natural,
the natural resources defense fund will,
will encourage the imposition of standards
so direct Konijn that they can't make
a living? Well, no,
they wouldn't have EDF as the lead agency.
If EDF we're of the same temperament.
Ash let's freak theater.
We saw in the video they chose EDF
quit cause they think they can cut a
plausible and constructive
bargain with them,
which liege not upper left upper right
in the diagram or emissions decrease in a
substantial degree.
And uh,
and profits remain hot.
This slide is in the is from the case
and it's the full inventory of exactions
that Jim March then and EDF people
consider in looking at the case and it,
if they call it the blue sky concessions
because it's perfectly clear they're
not going to get all of these,
but they want,
some of them are and they get some of
them and they also get quite a lot of
symbolic by him.
So let,
by the current year 2009 Kkr is
offering an investment portfolio,
wicked calls the green portfolio.
And this consists not of companies
that are going to devote themselves to
producing environmental products,
but random grid companies
which produce other products,
for example in bio mat, uh,
produce magical devices.
But we're,
they sign on to the proposition that they
will make their production process far
greener than it was before.
So that I as an investor can buy into
the Green Fund and expect market rates of
return and think that on the side I'm
doing a little bit of good for the
environment.
Yeah.
Big changes are on the horizon
for Texas power customers.
Welcome to the new TXU.
We've listened to Texans on prices and
we're taking a new approach to prove it.
Most residential customers will
get a double digit price cut.
We've listened to Texans on
the environment, so we'll cut,
propose to new coal units from 11 to
three and look for new ways to ensure
reliable, affordable power,
doing what's right for customers,
doing what's right for Texas.
Welcome to the future. Welcome.
Txu.
Okay. So, uh,
and they all went to the beach
and had a swell afternoon.
Um,
the,
okay, so that's the last case we're going
to do except the one for your final.
And what I hope you'll
do for Wednesday is, uh,
read Finnegan piece with some care.
He's a British writer.
I got to know him personally when he
came to write about a violent kids in new
haven 20 years ago.
Um,
and it's a beautifully written
piece and it's a compelling story.
And also begin reviewing your notes for
the big picture level of the course.